За даними звіту міжнародної агенції We are social,
25 з половиною мільйонів українців користуються інтернетом,
що становить 58%
від 44 мільйонів населення країни.
Міжнародний дослідницький холдинг Factum Group
у звіті Opinion Software Media порахував,
які сайти найбільше полюбляють українські користувачі комп’ютерів
і мобільних браузерів на Android.
За  даними дослідників, до заборони  російських сайтів у березні 2017 року
"Вконтакте", "Яндекс" та "Одноклассники"
були у топ 10-ці найбільш відвідуваних інтернет-сторінок  в Україні.
Відповідно розташувавшись на 2-му, 5-му і 7-му місцях за відвідуваністю.
А вже рік потому -  соцмережа "Вконтакте" з 2-го місця
скотилася на 9-те,  "Яндекс" -  з 5-го на 10-те,
"Одноклассники" взагалі вилетіли з першої десятки на 16-те місце.
Водночас спостерігається тенденція збільшення
українських користувачів у Facebook та Instagram.
За даними відповідних соцмереж, з січня 2017 року
по січень 2018 кількість користувачів  Facebook
збільшилася на 71%.
Загалом соцмережею щомісяця активно користуються
вже 13 мільйонів українців.
А кількість українців в Instagram -  понад 7 мільйонів користувачів,
це 16% від населення країни.